vediamo molto 20 bentornati sanità
stories
oggi nuova challenge non scegliere la
mette i box sbagliata però chi sceglierà
le piste box facoltà che si dirà a
berlino ancora società che un giorno io
mi chiedo ma ha sentito la mia voce ha
pensato di un comico tornato stanno
facendo quei due consentendo combinati
[Musica]
come il solito tecnico abbraccia la vita
[Risate]
che vuole che mi siedo allora si stava
nel caso perché lui quando vieni qua
vuole che vi spiego e di metodo di così
lui può stare comodo e dormire ma
stranamente già steso lungo lungo non ci
sta più e di merlino sceglierà ogni
turno una delle missioni pops ma in
turni per i box ci saranno cose
terribili invece una delle viste i boss
si sarà una sorpresa premi saranno le
new magic l'iter legis che potete
trovare in edicola
in pratica hanno agusta è enorme in cui
si può trovare una bambola alta di si
sentiva il tritium una casetta alta 13
cm e sono tutte da collezionare state
che peso
wow bellissime
quindi vediamo chi riuscirà a
collezionarne di più tra me e vitale e
alla fine del video potrete votare qual
è la vostra preferita
perché vedete si sono anche i vari
mestieri modella attrice cantante quindi
guardate il video fino alla fine per
votare la vostra preferita e le potete
trovare vinicola altre 150 ora siamo
pronti non vedo l'ora di spacchettare
tutte quindi spero di vincerne o per
pochi mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn e siamo subito ragione dopo il suo
sguardo migliore di sempre trovare 133
mistery box le posizioni amo a terra 1 2
e 3
e questo sarà il mio turno quindi
vediamo quale sceglie e merlino facciamo
rete una foto molto per questo turno
proveremo a ruby per le crocchette
vediamo se sceglie comunque lo studio
mettere le promette vediamo
[Musica]
che bravo che se è vero che berlino
vediamo cosa c'è in questa buche ma che
cari allora il sito pallavolo vediamo
cosa 5 la più vediamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
esatto perché lui ogni tanto mangiava
per quale abita le sim io per questo
turno non ho vinto niente anzi unito da
behrami
[Musica]
guardate berlino come incantato alla
somma la somma visto della pera quale
tre miseri box sono state posizionate
[Risate]
sceglie quella viola vista
[Applauso]
addio
avrete più cicli pelle di vediamo allora
abbiamo la casetta purtroppo avesse
capitate come la copertina prima ma
l'approccio la sua casetta ma la cosa
più bella non lo facciamo vedere a
berlino perché se non può essere che
sono mancini e carina per le struttu
lino e ovviamente con queste bamboline
si può giocare anche con le love price
eccole qua come se fossero tipo le
parenti tipo le cugine e ora passiamo al
prossimo turno mistery box vediamo cosa
ci capita allora andiamo a posizionare
le scatole di come le calabrie moscato 1
2 e 3
eccole qua e adesso facciamo entrare
berlino coronare processi quella verde
assetto brown reato proprio la prima che
sento vediamo un po cosa mi dia un
pochino mi chiamo viviamo
a berlino con sono dubbi ok abbiamo la
nostra casetta riccio dello studio di
registrazione
poi ecco la nostra lista alle di penso
che sia la cantante ora andiamo a
montarla montata con la sua casetta
studi di registrazione anche lo zainetto
incanti vini troppo carino ecco che
belle bellissime
ora passiamo al prossimo e ultimo turno
e il prossimo sarà l'ultimo turno epoca
ammirare e poi andremo ad aprire le
truppe che ci vediamo qual è quella che
ci piace di più che io ho posizionato le
mistery box
vediamo quale sceglierà ora merlino
entra pure berlino come
certo ha scelto quella viola
vediamo
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
berlino berlino scelto l'aglio allora
siccome lui si mostra tre scatolette
azzerò un limone
è quindi a sorprendere questo celeste si
no ora andiamo ad aprirle tutte ecco qua
la casetta questo è una pasticceria
vediamo un po la bambolina che bello
mettesse al sacco questa come vestita
questo vestitino vediamo l'animale è un
gattino bellissimo poi se la borsetta
apriamo la non divulgato il gatto nero
berlino ma finora questa è la mia
preferita perché investito in via san
salvo e anche il gattino mai ad aprirle
tutte a da eccoli qua tutte cose sono
carinissime con oddio quel cagnolino
bellissimo gatto tartarughina
carinissima un chihuahua che carino poi
c'è sempre una casetta dietro questa c'è
uscita doppia infatti evidente con la
turtle dinho e dico quale altre c'è
anche una lolli perché danno molto bene
assieme colle roll possono appunto
giocare assieme
allora la mia preferita
questa migrazione tocco con gli occhi
verdi e super carina però come
animaletto mi piace troppo questo
cagnolino è bellissimo con la linguetta
di fuori è carinissimo a te invece a me
piace tanto a questa che il paese si è
carina per calabi alla fine vita le
avevo ecco perché che carire quindi
queste sono le new magic lead ladies che
potete trovare in edicola
versate in pochi ce l'ha invece berlino
che sta dormendo all età comodissimo
leto politico de felice di dormire nel
letto comodo comodo garrido berlino fa
finta di non sentire berlino io so bene
come svegliarlo che strano si sveglia e
premiato alimentato profondamente allora
[Musica]
tre minuti no non glielo far mangiare
non eletto 2000 zkk di qui perrone dio
magic little lady due fermi piazza se
volete vedere altre challenge assieme ad
altri spacchettamenti contro kateryna su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite